powerful tornadoes ripped across
Oklahoma overnight tearing roofs off
homes and flipping over trucks at least
eight tornadoes touched down in the
state the highest ever recorded in the
month of February in the Oklahoma City
area alone several Twisters toppled
chimneys crumpled siding and sent debris
flying into the air Chelsea Riley said
the wind shattered the window right next
to her ten-year-old daughter's bed he
threw her blanket over her head and she
waited for me to come get her her
brother came screaming to her rescue and
I pushed him in the bathroom she said
she'd left them in the bathroom as she
raced to find her two other children
ages five and six when the wind calmed
down she saw just how much damage there
was there were shingles everywhere fence
panels broken we jumped in the car and
tried to leave and as I'm trying to get
out of my driveway things are broken
everywhere the dangerous system also
slammed Kansas at least two tornadoes
were confirmed in the state